good morning Millennials welcome back to
the morning toast
it's Thursday the week's so must over
the weeks so must over I can't wait to
have Theo sleep over what an amazing
week you guys it's Thursday like we're
home free no no I wish every week just
came as easy as this week did you know I
wish every day was Thursday I wish but
it ain't but it ain't but cos here our
third co-host they think we're gonna
offer him the full-time position yeah he
just brings so much to the show no like
value logistical II this company is
split 50-50 you know we both are equal
parts hard-working but I think you and I
should both take a major pay cut start
taking 20% each and then give Theo the
remaining 60 I think that we should be
33 3333 nobody to be honest like I don't
really feel like it would be fair to
Theo when he does so much more work than
it carries the load and I think a lot of
people pretty much like only tune in to
see him they don't really care about us
so he's like bringing us two new viewers
I just it wouldn't be fair it's true but
I mean if we're gonna meet technical
like most people listen as a podcast and
they don't even get to see him but maybe
true maybe you do get to hear his snores
and his licks of his bone
maybe people listening to the podcast
are so jealous that they can't see Theo
that it'll turn them into youtubers
wwe.com youtube.com slash Juanito
subscribe thanks love it also we
released our st. Patty's Day March
yesterday it is still available for
pre-order up until noon today so if you
didn't get your t-shirt make sure to get
one they're selling like hotcakes if
you're looking for pictures Jackie and I
are both are wearing size extra larges
on our Instagram the morning toast I'm
really excited to see toasters in the
wild on st. Patty's Day wearing that
March like it's soaked I think I have to
make some plans - I just have a party
totally don't live near any like fun
bars you know I actually live sort of me
over well you have a party oh yeah you
know what I haven't had a real party at
night and by the way your friend Becky
who listens to our podcast she texts me
yesterday cuz we were talking about day
drinking she was asking me for
recommendations of like a club to go to
for her birthday and she was like what I
kind of wanted arty cuz like you guys
were talking about the podcast I'm like
Becky have a dartie I'll have the
pregame for it the dartie anything her
birthday does fall around st. Patty's
Day it actually does okay good to know
while speaking of Becky the red
but club first episode is up if you
haven't read the book still listen to
the episode we're recording the next
episode next week and then it wraps on
the first Thursday of March so get
caught up it's such a wonderful
community that's such a great week for
podcasts the first week of March
just think of March is a big week for
tannins yeah we have another show
launching I hate to be annoying but I
love the toasters actually not ten times
out of ten always guess what we're doing
but I don't know if they're gonna know
who this podcast is with so that's gonna
be really exciting first week of March
like they can read our body like we
don't know I like you can't get away
into anything like I have like an
insecurity in my head and then someone
types it out in the Facebook group I'm
like how the [ __ ] did you know that yeah
it's really crazy they're just so in
tune with us I saw someone wrote a post
in the toaster it's like I truly feel
like Jackie and Claudia are my friends
and then like I'll see something that
makes me want to text them and then I
realize I don't have their number but
just write it in the group she said that
her Cavalier made a really smelly fart
oh we can relate I've been up all night
this week at literally been gets into
bed at 11 p.m. and he's like could we
watch vlog squad and we've been watching
like hunt there's over like I think
there's almost a thousand blogs and he
has two YouTube channels so me and Ben
have been watching David Roberge vlogs
and I find myself talking like him and
his friends there what do they say yeah
bro so it was like calling each other
fat like being front of each other like
joking about how they all like use David
for Klout and for money and it's really
funny but it's like it's a harsh
environment like I don't think I could
ever be friends with them because
they're so mean to each other in a
joking way so me and Ben like we're just
we go to bed like oh you [ __ ] [ __ ]
like I'm just being crazy and it's
really impacting it's like when you go
to camp and you talk like your camp
friends I'm talking like my vlog friends
and they need to stop I mean it's like
how everyone talks like a toaster right
Kurt's into the situation everything of
the sort totally um okay well we have a
great show today we're gonna recap real
houses of New Jersey which was fabulous
I have been watching housewives for
years and especially I've been watching
Jersey housewives for a while and it
hasn't been good like it used to be in a
really long time and last night's
episode was insane not only did it have
so much heart he was hysterical the
husbands were cracking me up I was dying
at Bill Eden but then the ending I
didn't even realize we were gonna be
getting a footage moment like there was
a receipt there was footage and I think
the use of the idea of them putting it
in the show not in real time was very
interesting a very strategic viewer
would have been so frustrated we'll talk
about it we'll get to it also speaking
of TNN I am where
i Lauren Elizabeth sweater oh my god by
the way I literally got that in white
and almost work today oh my god that's
so crazy when I first got it I was like
oh there's no way this is gonna look
cute with my jugs but it's just
everything I'm loving it it's I love a
cropped turtleneck Thank You Lauren I'm
wearing an Alexander Wang sweater which
is just so not like waiting I am part of
winging and you know the only reason
that I bought the sweater even though it
was like crazy expensive for essentially
like a wife beater which by the way do
we still say wife beater no but we
haven't replaced the term rate tank top
no but it ain't how it's a different
thing right okay so I only bought this
because you convinced a and you look
fabulous yeah this one my second time
wearing and I forgot that I had it like
when you spend so much money on an item
like my fanny jacket you have to wear
the [ __ ] out of it the great thing about
this is you could wear it a million
different ways because it's a basic it's
so simple yes so elegant it's such a
staple totally anyways are you ready to
get into it already I know you know what
I've actually been feeling like truly
are th that I miss our sponsors no I
know everywhere there's so much color to
the show they're hilarious by the way
everyone knows we're not doing sponsors
this week because this week Jackie and I
months ago had planned to both take off
like ten days for our high V in Hawaii
yeah I was supposed to be like somewhere
off the coast of Mexico and we just
decided like a month ago that we just
didn't have the time to take a honeymoon
so once again our honeymoons have both
been pushed off and we had canceled the
shows of this week so when we decided to
come back it was too late for us to get
the brands on board so that's why this
week has been rent free yeah but like
otos whoever you're shopping I always
assumed that you know the sponsors were
like you know weighing us down and you
know you have to fit them in but I I
miss them I truly miss them they're
hysterical or hysterical they contribute
so much to the show but you know what's
really the show is all about do tell it
is time for the fast facts stories that
you need to know before you wake up and
take a bite out of your morning toast
crunch or if your CEO is the your
morning bone Oh or if you're been it's
your morning bone Oh God okay sorry Oh
God okay sorry okay
first story such exciting news you guys
bethany frankel is announcing a business
competition series at HBO max the bee is
back yes but the real houses of new New
York alum has scored an 8 episode order
at the nascent streamer of the big shot
with Bethany in the half-hour series
aspiring moguls will compete for a
chance to win a spot on the executive
team of Frankel's lifestyle brand
Skinnygirl this series will be produced
by MGM television
be real productions and big fish
Entertainment Franco will executive
produce along with Mark Burnett berry
posnick and dances REO so this is very
much like an apprentice yes by Japanese
competition show which I'm really
excited to have Bethany back on my
screens I feel like I'm really gonna
miss her on this upcoming season of New
York but like mm-hmm
no it's just the show's not about
Bethenny like at all it's about the
contestant and it's like I love Bethenny
on Shark Tank
I love Bethenny on rioni yeah it's like
Project Runway you don't watch Project
Runway for Heidi Klum right so it's for
Carly class it's exciting to that she's
like venturing and Mark Burnett is so
prestigious he's a creator of Shark Tank
so she obviously like really hit it off
with him when she was on Shark Tank and
I'm happy for her and her networking
skills and it will definitely be
watching this because the more I hear
about HBO max liked the more convinced
am that I must subscribe yeah but um I
don't know it's just like I'm sure I'll
love it but it's just not really what I
was hoping for I don't know what I was
hoping for I was hoping for literally a
reality show of Bethenny in her child
honestly until I read this article I
thought it was gonna be remember how we
would watch for Honi and she would just
be in the back of the car crying and
we're like we want to show about this
like her little life is interest like
what are the things stressing about
what's going on in the business she's
selling half of Skinnygirl like she's
talking to her driver she has no friends
like I wanted that reality show like 30
minutes of just Bethenny I thought that
this was it yeah I had a feeling she was
gonna do something a little bit more
business focus just because like her
exit from Rohani I think was an attempt
to make her a little bit more
professional like with the shark tank
and everything but um and and I'm sure
it's gonna be good I'm not trying to
down it at all but like it's just not
what I was expecting and I could use a
little bit more personal path any
moments but I think that's why she found
Housewives and left Housewives because
it was so personal my kind of toxic for
her personal life yeah but also the
women create so much drama and like she
very already lives like such a dramatic
life yeah she doesn't need those extra
elements agreed it was a toxic
environment it was just like a fly on
the wall camera you know they could just
broadcast her her nest camera yeah like
in her office with all those girls who
work for her mom toasters like I don't
need contrived storylines they just want
to see her in in her element
yeah with be strong you know there's
just so much there there's so much
tragedy in the world and Bethenny is
constantly helping I think that a
docu-series documenting the life of
Bethenny would have been super
interesting but I understand why she
felt
SiC and I think the business route is
great for her I think that Skinnygirl
continues to grow and be really
successful and she wants to be taken
more seriously as a businesswoman more
so than a reality star so I get it but
also this is the first project under her
deal with MGM television and Mark
Burnett so I think it's the first of
many and it doesn't that doesn't mean
that we're not ever gonna get bethenny
reality totally there's hope there's but
HBO max is just churning out the content
we have the Brad and Gary show on HBO
max yeah friends is gonna be on HBO max
I heard the gossip girl reboots gonna be
on there too is Gary's cartoon show on
HBO max I think I got a subscribe yeah
no I is it out no no now like I'm ready
I'm ready
I hate when they talk about streaming
services before they launch like kwibi
I've been seeing so much press for quick
she even April I saw a commercial for it
and then it said April I've just I've
been in meetings like with brands and
like networks and like literally for the
last five years people been saying
Jeffrey Katzenberg's is quit quit quit
I'm like oh yeah quitter you having
company now it's like here but it's not
even here and I'm just so done and I
haven't even heard I haven't even seen a
quitting show but I'm done with it
because it hasn't launched yet
I hate [ __ ] that just talks and doesn't
launch yeah I will say though that could
be like the talent that they've lined up
does look very promising
of course they spent literally a billion
dollars just on celebrities which is all
you need yeah yeah the Kardashian
Chrissy Teigen many shows Tyler say
exactly
what more could you ask for than the
Kardashians in Tyler see nothing okay
next story is really sad but Real
Housewives of Beverly Hills star Teddy
Mellencamp is mourning the rapper pop
smoke wait this story is obviously
tragic what's so strange day the the
Teddy Mellencamp element so yesterday
Brooklyn born twenty-year-old welcome to
the party rapper was shot and killed at
a party at the house and appears in what
appears to be a home invasion robbery
then it came out that the house is owned
by Teddy and her husband her husband and
that it was being rented out right so
she posted early this a.m. we were
informed by a third-party leasing and
management company overseeing a rental
home we owned in Los Angeles that a
shooting had taken place at the property
she said on Instagram foremost we would
like to extend our prayers and
condolences to the family and loved ones
affected by the tragic loss of life this
is such a sad story such a weird turn of
event
like I first of all a 20 year old died
in a home invasion robbery is literally
the saddest thing I've ever heard
regardless of whether or not he was like
famous or not but now like a lot of
people are feeling really sad because
they loved his music yeah then Teddy
Mellencamp just like strangely being
involved it's just so weird I wonder if
this was the house that they lived in
previously because they just moved into
the bigger house and you could you saw
in the last season of housewives or they
just owned a bunch of properties that's
like one of their business ventures so
here's a photo of the house I don't
recognize it
as the one that they used to live in
actually but I don't remember it I
didn't have a really steep driveway when
they brought that bus up or was that the
second house that was I think the second
house what I remember about Teddy
Mellencamp's first house was that it
looked just like a house from Real
Housewives of Orange County oh that does
I mean that does kind of look like it
innocent we can't cannot confirm nor
deny whether or not this was the house
season one teddy was filmed in know but
it's just a very sad story two men
wearing masks and hooded sweatshirts
burst into the house where the rising
star was staying at around 4:30 a.m.
local time and fired off multiple
gunshots what the [ __ ] like everyone you
know there is a crime spree my dog
walker call me yesterday said his
apartment was broken into while he was
in there what if he was in the Marines
so he was good he was like they
literally ran away from me but like what
the [ __ ] what the [ __ ] so he was telling
me he like was busy with the police he
probably was gonna be able to walk Theo
this morning I was like I kind of
understand it's totally fine but like
what the [ __ ] people just like roaming
into other people's apartments coming on
thanks really scary I know oh my gosh
well this is very sad like all around
thinking of everyone involved very sad
um wonder if Teddy is like one of this
affects her business you know I'm sure
it's it can't be good rental business
it's not no one wants to stay in the
house at someone was shot up yeah but
it's just purely coincidence I'm
assuming they I don't think Teddy and
Edwin are involved okay next story is
really shocking to me you didn't seem so
shocked well I didn't seem so shocked
because you found out about it when you
found this story and I heard about this
yesterday Riverdale's start Madeleine
patch and her boyfriend Travis Mills
have broken up yeah I saw someone posted
this in the Facebook group which is how
I find all my news and if you're not in
our Facebook group you should definitely
be in it yeah membership is open you
guys wide open the floodgates are open
you just got to answer the questions in
a meaningful way and you are in it's not
like how it used to be so I feel like
worth Knox Judaism you know to come
right three times before you are
accepted I saw the link and I
pass it really quickly and I swear my
life I thought it was Jackie like she
looked so much like Madeline patch
freaks me I'm like what my sister is
getting a divorce
thank you that's really flattering uh I
never see it I never feel that but why
do you see this was a while back and I
haven't addressed it yet yes yes I saw
hey so a few weeks ago the toaster said
someone found in act I was like a
targeted Facebook guy yeah digital ad
where was a bunch of people at tables I
think was for like a shared workspace it
was called square it was called square
and one of the models she's turned to
the side she's working at a desk and the
toasters were convinced even like day
one toasters who know every facet of my
face they were convinced sister and I
thought it was you
everyone thought it was me I never said
whether it was or it wasn't is it it's
not me no but like I you come almost
like it's just shocking someone's like
she talked about having an agent one so
maybe this is what they got for her Ted
I mean honestly it's concerning I would
love to hear from someone at corporate
and square who the model is or what
digital like holographic image they put
together to look like you yeah it was
crazy you guys but it's like I didn't I
didn't totally see it but I saw it
completely fact that you did like made
me realize that there was merit but I
feel like sometimes I see someone who I
think looks like you but you don't see
it at all yeah I mean I just find that
whenever someone like thinks someone
looks like me like I'm just bound to be
insulted and I don't really like look at
the person because I just don't want to
realize like that's what you think I
look like I mean how many times and by
the way she's beautiful and I actually
take the compliment like how many times
are people gonna tell me I look like
beanie Feldstein like no we actually
looked nothing like we're both just like
a little chubby brunette and Jewish I
think it's a vibe it's a wire don't care
we don't look alike I stand by that we
don't look like someone said that they
took the cover of books Martin they said
gonna tell my kids this was Jackie and
Claudia okay that's a funny joke
cuz together of course the vibe by the
way that the second girl book-smart
how is she not Kay Panabaker no she's
like stunt on these hoes at all the
award shows because book-smart got
nominated for a bunch of things and
she's just like living the life that
girl she's very talented actress I like
you um she's also in the Netflix series
um one about a court case [ __ ]
unbelievable yeah I wouldn't see it yeah
it was on my list to watch
but instead I could watch bring it on
chair smack um anyways laughter
Maddalena Travis have split this is
really shocking to me they've been
together for a really long time I feel
like there were a few times where I
hadn't seen pictures of them in a while
I would go to their instagrams and then
I would see that they were you know just
together but living their separate lives
right works a lot he's like a musician
he lives in Vancouver for Riverdale he
does go sit with Rachel Lindsay so we
have no choice but to stay on course and
he also has like an apple music beats
one show he's just like a man about town
and so is she
whenever you bring up ghosted with
Rachel Lindsay it reminds we have the
brilliant pilot that you championed and
then we tried to get made it MTV and
like our meeting to go anywhere but it
was the best idea ever it was like a
spin-off of ghost had called trolled
we're like internet celebrities or
celebrities would go to houses of people
who are writing me things about them on
the internet and hopefully it'll like
it'll influence our culture and like
scare them into stop doing it so I
didn't realize that these are people I
thought that was a really good idea
maybe we should launch like a pilot on
our YouTube where it's like we go to the
house of someone that we've plenty of
Charles who we know by name well yeah we
could just go to their place of work
like in Florida or something and
confront them and be like honey I'm a
person like can you stop being mean to
me yeah like you every let's talk about
it in a civil manner yeah let me explain
to you why I'm not the devil I love that
idea but then the issue is would people
feel more inclined to be troll so that
they would end up on the show I know but
I don't think ending up on the show as
like a troll is what yeah do you want to
be known for fishing people because they
wanted to be on the show I feel like
when Nev would call them they'd be like
no I'm not being on the show right now I
think that statistically catfish
definitely helped the statistics of
people being catfish it has to have you
mean it brought it down and brought it
up I think down I think down to it's
just like how teen mom brought teen
pregnancy it's a you city like more
people got pregnant cuz they wanted to
be on t no they saw how disgusting it
was and didn't want a part of it yeah
and how difficult it can be
yeah sorry I don't mean to say
disgusting that's mean I take it back
I'm sorry I'm sorry trials and
tribulations the Charles and tribulation
so being a teenage mom yeah anyways oh
yeah so they broke up but this is remind
me this is like a formula there are tons
of different ways that celebrity couples
break up especially ones that have been
together for a long time sometimes they
just break up out of nowhere Vanessa and
Hudgens and
whatever his name was Vic and you're
just shocked and you feel like you need
two more in the relationship when they
broke up for a second I was shocked but
then the next second I was like I wonder
what took them so long no I thought they
were Jewish she's like it's like it
never happened she's not sad yeah we're
at least she doesn't seem sad she's just
like being the age but to me this is
like another type of breakup it's like
if the formula where you just go quietly
into the night and then at people like
pick their heads up one day and they're
like wait this not posting together and
then you just like very quietly broke up
like this is I feel like we're comin
like ABEO and Shawn Mendes might be
heading because they've been really
quiet I saw it what he could only hope I
saw a tweet that said Shawn Mendes would
have never gotten famous if his name was
spelled s II am so true so true and you
know what people really don't talk about
enough how Shawn Mendes started on mine
I just think for a digital creator like
myself like we have no choice but to
respect him yeah I think Camila Kibeho
and Shawn Mendes are gonna keep are
they're still at it they're very quiet I
just saw a paparazzi picture of them you
did they were celebrating Valentine's
Day oh that's cute
um I am sad for Madeline and Travis I
think I think that she's probably really
sad about it yeah I did was so in love
and like they just they were they just
understood each other I see and I did
always feel like they were a mismatch no
but that's what made them a match you
know it's like oh wow what an odd couple
what an odd couple they love each other
totally like despite all the odds yeah
yeah that's true so I'm but this is fine
they're both like young Hollywood
hopefully Madeline could date someone
like a little bit more famous than her
to like rise her star a little bit maybe
like an athlete or an actor should be
just fine
you need to do someone like another
competing like teen show you know Oh
like like Oh like a Ross Butler you know
or like a 13 reasons why someone from
there you know someone who can give her
more Instagram followers yeah okay there
are tons of shows like that oh she does
have a lot of Instagram followers yeah
yeah we're like a youtuber because she's
really maximizing her Brad she's being
so smart because she's using all of her
Riverdale Fame channeling into a YouTube
channel said if it all goes to [ __ ] she
love her YouTube channel just like Shay
Mitchell who literally is the richest
out of all them because she had a
YouTube channel when she was on Pretty
Little Liars
it's a genius move did you watch her
Vogue makeup tutorial Emily no oh it's
great for grad heads oh yeah I was gonna
say like can't relate to her makeup
tutorial like whatsoever I we couldn't
be more different looking
sometimes does her own makeup on the
show she said oh each is really
interesting well when we did the vogue
day in the life of kami Mendes she said
that she does her own eyeliner as
Veronica yeah which I totally get
Madelyn does her own lips too but
sometimes she does her whole thought
interest - yeah she seems really like an
expert
I just you can't imagine having access
to like a full hair and makeup trailer
and wanting to do any of it myself
yeah but it just saves time and like I'm
sure getting your full thoughts done
like caked on every single day isn't a
dream a dream is not funny a dream on
your skin and it's like if I'm gonna be
on TV I want to be caked on like I don't
look like anything like myself I feel
that it's not good for your skin though
that's for sure yeah okay next story a
little happy relationship news because
Jenna Dewan is engaged TIFF she is yet
to stop to trial and go to trial a
composer Steve Kazee who is yeah he's on
that song we've had this conversation
like a remix of a thousand years by
Christina Perri what is he he's a music
guy like a musician or like us she
scores films he is I think it's more in
the film variety yeah I don't know of
him as a musician he's just he had more
money than her ooh that's a good
question because I feel like she's so
public yeah but like where's the money
coming from
right that's might be so private and the
money's coming in we talk about this all
the time like being a celebrity does not
mean that you're rich and there are
plenty of celebrities who like don't
really work and I'm so confused about
how they make their money like Jenna
Dewan she does host So You Think You Can
Dance and that's on and network so like
that's definitely a lot of money yeah so
I think her and the kids are fine but I
think like when she was married like the
Channing Tatum money was like the family
money so now she's on her own and I just
I I wonder about her finances but if
Steve Kazee is Evan yes I'm gonna Google
him so he can find out exactly what he
does for the millionth time I feel like
my Google should just know the questions
I'm about to ask like Chris respond okay
he is an American actor in singer he won
the 2012 Tony Award for Best Performance
by a leading actor in a Musical for once
that's really cool so he's a Broadway
he's music okay uh yeah he I guess he's
a man like he does it all I feel like he
could be Annie got mmm I can really as a
fellow person who does it all he's been
in he's been in some TV shows Walking
Dead shameless Nashville
he plays riff Chanel's show me picture
of him okay I feel like we've been
talking about her boyfriend for a while
and I just like think of him as a
faceless man and they actually are
pregnant yes right I'm really they're
really so cute oh by the way he looks
like the lead singer of Old Dominion I
mean by the way anyone is so hot we just
got a TV in our studio cuz we ordered
two from Target and they both came
broken to me like it was a whole ordeal
and we just got it hung and I we really
only got it so we could like watch
screen or some TV shows and play music
around the office so yesterday I played
a YouTube playlist of like country music
videos and I just have to say justice
for music videos like I never really
understood recently like why they're
still being made but totally yesterday I
totally understood I was watching so
many music videos like the holy Florida
Georgia line music video when they were
literally 16 and both of their wives and
are in it iconic Darius Rucker doing a
music video for wagon-wheel with the
entire cast of duck dynasty and the Lady
Antebellum group like there's just so
many nuances that go into oh oh I'm
sorry at this close to Adele newzik
video where that race car driver girl
who dated Aaron Rodgers is named Anika
is that her name yeah she was in it like
I was let's together give this celebrity
cameos like it's just feel like all this
money production time resources go into
music videos and nobody cares but I care
they're like marketing tools right and
some of them hit really big and go viral
but other times it's just like okay the
song came out and now we want you to get
care about it again here's a music video
yeah and you know what it's funny to see
how like so why why I brought this up is
because Old Dominion was on that play
that's like five times and they were
like so busy like this last year when
all their music came out didn't have
time to shoot a music video
literally all their music videos or them
singing out their concerts cuz they were
on tour so they had a man with a camera
just filming it was actually pretty
genius that's that's pretty good
[ __ ] what was I gonna say I had like
three things oh did you see that video
of the girl in the subway singing
shallow the stage video yeah I'm
convinced it staged oh well to me I like
I mean she was fabulous was that looks
like Hannah jeez mom yeah well how did
she commented on the picture was like
mom question mark yeah yeah yeah think
about the woman's hair was just too
perfectly quaffed and like she looked so
effortless in the New York City Subway
first of all where was her coat like it
just it seemed so sad really
yeah oh I'm so naive I just said like oh
no I will die on the hill of that this
video was staged and by the way good for
her because net were all talking about
her in other ways
incredible and maybe I'm just jealous of
her voice but it was staged okay what
was she doing with a perfectly quaffed
blowout and a latte and no jacket in the
New York City subway fabulous New Yorker
okay that's just not logistically like
it doesn't make sense
we were surcoat and her gloves it was
freezing yesterday I'll have to look
into it again maybe she took it off
inside her arm maybe
okay fifth and final story Michaela
Spielberg Steven Spielberg's daughter
I'm so glad you buzzed out as a porn
star I just want to say I think we
should reserve the word comes out for
people who are actually coming out like
of the closet I didn't think being a
porn star requires a coming-out moment
it's a New York Post headline and when I
saw it I thought the same thing okay um
but so she has announced that she is a
porn star Michaela Spielberg 23 the
daughter of legendary filmmaker Steven
Spielberg and his actress wife Kate
Capshaw revealed Wednesday that she is
starring in her own solo porn videos the
Nashville Tennessee resident also
announced to the US son that she hopes
to score an exotic dancing gig as soon
as she hustles up her state strippers
license which is reportedly quite
difficult to obtain the et directors
child says she told her parents about
her Close Encounters of the x-rated kind
over the weekend via FaceTime Michaela
admits she suffered with anxiety during
childhood and going to boarding school
on her teens led to eating disorders and
depression but she doesn't blame her
famous folks it's not my parents fault
she says they couldn't have known she
did a whole interview with the son
talking about um you know her choice to
porn go into porn she says it's not an
I've hit bottom choice for her because
you know what it's an empowered choice
to be honest I just don't really know
what to say here because I don't want
any no just respect porn stars or
strippers because every choice wannabe
his point sorry was Sherbourne I don't
care but you know for a lot of people
it's like you know a last resort and I
just think like to be so spoiled is like
out of control uh yeah I mean they
obviously both have you know an affinity
for film mm-hmm runs in the family
yeah I mean he must be so proud
overwhelmed with joy I mean it's it's
almost not fair you know it's just so
beautiful yeah
I'm happy for her trying to toe the line
of like not disrespecting like because
to be honest like if you want to be a
porn star like that is 100% your choice
and I empower you to do so if you want
to be a stripper like I think that's
great I just went to a strip club
I love strippers I just I just think
most of the people who are doing porn
and are in a strip club are doing so
because of like the situation's of their
life experience that led them there like
I don't think they wanted to grow up and
be a porn star I just don't think that
so for someone who was probably had
everything handed to her like this just
seems like a bratty thing like oh but
like jizz away my pads and maybe I'm a
porn star yeah oh I didn't see it like
that I watched a slasher movie once am a
queer student about the college the Duke
porn star I think she went to Duke and
she's in college and she was having
trouble with money and she went into
porn and at first it was like not you
know she didn't really like know the
right way to go about it and it was kind
of sad but then eventually like she saw
it as this really empowering thing and
she became like just really outspoken
about how porn was such a positive thing
for her but I don't know I think it left
the question of what was on lifetime
yeah cuz it was based on a true story
let him so weird cuz they'll put that
out and then it's like I watch this
terrible Mayim Bialik movie where she
was like this half Jewish half Christian
girl who fell in love with a man that
you met in an inn because their flight
got diverted during Christmas time
here's the thing about lifetime it gets
very much confused with Hallmark but
it's so not calmer no trust me I watched
one of their want to be hallmark movies
when I was on tour and it was the only
channel me and Margo had and this Mayim
Bialik movie was so horrible like to
even compare it to a hallmark movie
would be a trauma stand it's like they
put out these movies that are like
Christmas hallmark movies but then also
a lot of them are like you know the
Britney Spears murder movies yeah I
think you could just turn on lifetime
and you have no clue what you're about
to work but that's so true I feel like
when I like well kissing and either one
person is gonna murder the other or
they're gonna get married yeah when we
were kids life time was like the murder
mystery like the SVU fictional movies
yeah but now I think of it more as like
wannabe hallmark yeah yeah I think
they're struggling I think they are too
I think like the rise of Hallmark
definitely impacted their business if I
had to assume and they also do like drum
overdramatize like celebrity memoirs
like Riley and Megan Britney Spears are
Kelly and Nicole Smith I watched that
for you know and then they did the are
Kelly documentary it's very this all
over the place they see the College
Admission scandal movie
I couldn't even get through it I didn't
start it but I was also like so hung
over it was when we were in LA when you
were doing your show oh yeah that's
crazy
that was so crazy yeah um so those are
the past five stories that you needed to
know
they were very fast very fast very five
though
yeah very five let's talk about Real
Housewives of New Jersey because I am
just feeling so like excited about the
future you know what I mean
Jersey has been a rough ride you know we
started out so strong almost too strong
season one and then the whole show was
like incumbent and the first three
seasons were fantastic and then we fell
into the slump with like Joe and Teresa
and then they went to jail we got those
two twins and Amber Marchese and like it
was just rough and we slowly started to
come out of that and I think we're at a
good place now but I didn't know when I
sat down to watch last night's episode
that I was gonna be watching the best
episode of real houses in New Jersey in
recent memory I just didn't know that no
I didn't know and that made it better it
was very unassuming yeah because it just
masses itself is a great episode all the
guys were having so much fun and during
the showing of Real Housewives they used
to take couples trips like some trips
were just girls trips and some general
couples trip and we haven't had a
franchise take a couples trip in so long
and obviously for Jersey it was
pertinent because the we love the men as
much as if not more as we love the women
so their best friend it made total sense
but I just love this dynamic of like the
women being there with their husbands it
just made the trip seemed so much more
fun as opposed to like I know that you
know you're on this trip because it's a
work trip Jackie I totally agree it made
the episode so much more dynamic and I
think like when I think back to real
houses in New York they took one trip
when they when Aviva Drescher bought her
brought her husband and it was a girls
trip that was like the last time any man
ever went on an episode I mean it went
on a trip and I think it's because I
think a lot of the women go on the show
and get divorced so they don't have men
yeah and it's like either they go on the
show and get divorced or they go on the
show it's a hot like knowing that like
the show can be toxic for a relationship
so they keep their husband off-camera
like I'd share the Jane and Tom like Tom
wouldn't absolutely never go on a tray
and she's protecting him and like I
think of Beverly Hills a lot a lot of
those husbands would never go on a trip
I don't even think Harry Hamlin would go
on a trip no but there was a time when
like Mauricio Ken yes when they went to
Hawaii and the magazine's yes and now
he's a couples trip but now it's just
everything has changed where it's like
either you put your relationship on the
show too much and it's a negative or you
just are cautious and you don't do it at
all but I think in Jersey
like it's just it's such a good thing
yeah and the like I feel as though the
relationships aren't so tenuous you know
I'm not worried about Melissa and Joe
Gorga I'm not worried about Jackie and
Evan or worried Jennifer and Bill
definitely not worth worried about
Margaret and Joe Joe so not worry about
and I'm definitely not worried about
Dolores and Frank ya know like they're
really bad away when they cast I died we
have and you know what like I I started
to wonder why isn't she just with Frank
I know he broke her heart a long time
ago but you know she's obviously
forgiven him if he's around all the time
and when he said that he doesn't trust
himself to not you know betray her again
and he would never want to do that to
her again it just was really sweetie it
was sad though no but if you're taking
your pants I know maybe it's really hard
for him I can't relate I can't relate
but maybe it is maybe he'll get like we
were saying yesterday maybe he'll get to
a point in his life when he's you know
had his pee and everything and he said I
just miss Dolores you know what's
interesting though about the dynamic
with the men is that when that woman's
fights like interfere with the man's
relationship because like when Margaret
and Joe left because of Bill and
Jennifer the next day they all went
fishing and like all the guys were fine
yeah that's something that has to be
like an unwritten rule where it's like
you can't let the women's relationship
affect the men if they're truly friends
because it just gets weird I mean watch
I'm really not trying to watch the real
husband and then it's like the next
morning after that big fight Joe Benigno
went into the kitchen and Jennifer was
there he just said hey like it wasn't
yeah I like that the fight solely exists
in like the atmosphere of the women and
it doesn't usually go beyond that and it
doesn't fracture the friendships of the
men because I love the friendship of the
men and I don't want Joe Benigno not to
be friends with Billy then and they
should be friends and or Evan and Bill
and Bill and Evan are actually seem like
really good friends evan is everything
no he's this match Larry and he seems
like a really cool guy who's also a good
husband and dad good husband and dad
like cool gets along with everyone just
like what's wrong with him no no I know
and like the fact that like he chose
Jackie like makes me like Jackie like I
just think like from where I started in
the beginning of the season like knowing
that I was on the wrong side but like
really wanting to be like Jennifer
Dolores and Teresa's champion to where I
am now which is like honestly I used to
think Dolores was like the voice of
reason and I realized that she is
nothing of the sort now Jennifer who I
love is out of control and Teresa is the
worst of them all I'm like so I have
flipped completely and I'd liked I
actually I loved
Margaret and Melissa I just like
couldn't get on board with Jackie and I
didn't like like the vibe that jackie
was bringing to that group but now I'm
like 100% on the other side I'm team
mini-golf it's just Jackie and Margaret
are unbelievable are just rational
people yeah and sometimes that's
annoying when you're watching a TV show
yeah you know and like you want them to
just accept Jennifer the way she is but
like some of the [ __ ] she's saying it's
not cool and like we're rationally upset
about it yeah and I think that when in
the beginning of the season when her the
dumb stuff she was saying like I could
get past like her making the video of
Marian Webster like I actually thought
that was funny but now the stuff she's
saying is so terrible that I can't even
defend it like the stuff about her
parenting and about the pizza and the
party and Mara calling her I don't know
kind of mother you are Margaret like
just really saying horrible things and
not that people aren't saying mean
things back to her but I just think
she's taking everything to a level where
it's literally in defense it doesn't
need to go there yeah but like at the
same time like Margaret should not have
said that thing about working is not
being a fun being up but Margaret was
like what shouldn't push the head about
Margaret piss margaret off and she
flipped back on her but also like what
Jennifer said about Margaret it's true
like Margaret was opening up about like
something she hasn't talked a lot about
yep she was clearly teary-eyed and
you're just gonna cut her down and say
it's not it was so rad bad it was so
rude it was so rude so yeah she's gonna
say something mean in return agreed the
boys fishing trip honestly looked so fun
the episode was like making me like want
to like be in summertime like drinking
rose' like they just looked like they
were having so much fun they were
drinking everywhere like at the jinx
which by the way jinx was a very popular
spot on Jersey Shore yeah I'm loving the
crossover they drank there they drank at
the house and they drink at the dinner
the drink on the boat they drink at
minigolf like they just drank everywhere
which is so fun yeah it really felt like
a Jersey Shore weekend that they were
just happy to be there yeah and I just I
feel like they're all excited to be in
each other's company which makes me
excited to be watching it yeah I totally
agree the fact that they're at the
Jersey Shore and they're obviously like
just so comfortable themselves and
Melissa was just being so cute about
being so proud of being from the Jersey
Shore totally I just like I really like
love these women and when Bill Eden got
so drunk that they had to fireman carry
him out of the car and they being his
head on the door his head and they
probably could cause him % that was so
funny so so funny I love the
when he was the turkish guido oh my god
Tony Tony the Turkish we know that was
one of the funniest things I've ever
seen in my life no it was truly
beautiful it was beautiful and you know
who I have to love because all of this
wouldn't exist without him is Joe Gorga
yeah he brings all these guys together
fostered this like very like family bond
yeah like he became close with Joe
Benigno and and he's close with Frank
and he's good as they brought Evan yeah
and he is right reason for the season
you Jackie you're so right even though
he's not like sometimes he says things
and it's not the right thing to say and
he obviously talked about you know
affirming sex with his wife and that
wasn't appropriate it's like we have no
choice but to stand because he also
owned his [ __ ] and apologized yeah like
how rational is that it's the perfect
housewife no he's the perfect character
for the like oh you're so red I didn't
realize that like two seasons ago him
and Joe became really good friends and
then the next season they became really
good friends with Frank and then they
opened it up to the new guys like you're
so right and they brought even mardian
yeah yeah it's just like he's everything
of the sort and I'm happy that he it's
all of his hard work over the seasons is
paying off on this trip so like his
relationship with Melissa like the age
to perfect it's it's so beautiful like
how much he loves her and let's still
think I love you the same now that I did
when I met you on the Jersey Shore all
these years ago they're really like one
of the best couple agreed across the
franchise I totally agree and it's just
nice to watch the episode came to a
climax obviously when Melissa went to
meet Danielle for a job at Jamba Juice
and Danielle dropped the major bomb and
I was actually really proud of Melissa
for just rolling in there I think
Melissa sometimes just wants like be a
people pleaser
she was just like I spoke to all the
girls we don't be afraid anymore like
she was just very matter-of-fact about
it and I really appreciated that but the
whole conversation was confusing to me
because at first I was like why would
Melissa even go with meeting Ellen film
with her this is weird they had to get
this bug out they had to have checks
play so then it was like okay maybe so
we could know for certain that Danielle
won't be on the show anymore in there
just want us to like see how that's
gonna go down yeah because no it was
clear that Danielle had something that
she would say she called producers
producers made her meet with Melissa but
I'm so thankful for all of it like
Melissa's saying I spoke to all the
girls and we don't you in our group
anymore like that just seems like a
really formal statement to make when
Danielle's not in the group yeah no he's
friends with one person in the group
it's
really unnecessary so I was like
confused that's why it was even
happening but now I understand why so I
was ship when she said to first of all
Stephen Dan saying that's so strange
do you think you say something out
Stephen Dan yes I met him oh my god
guess I met him at Paris Hilton's
birthday party oh my god and I was like
I know you and he was like I know you
I'm like you do my gear from Roseau to
Jersey um Teddy say pull her hair did he
tell you to pull his hair
no but like I wish that the party was
tomorrow you know like so I could ask um
but him and his wife were literally so
nice like lovely and his bow this is why
I was telling you about it his wife like
he's super successful in fashion but his
wife is even more successful she I met
her she was such a nice lady she like
started J Brand sold it and now started
lashon's I love lujan and I said I might
you know hear your number one customer
is his Ramona Singer she's always on her
Instagram like talking about her
lashawn's pants she was like we know we
send Ramona a bunch of stuff oh my god I
would love to get some lashawn's we took
Dana for a shopping makeover a few weeks
ago because she needs up she really
needed it and we took her to saxony
bought her three pairs of lashon's jeans
to just totally transform her wardrobe
oh this she's like so short and I was
worried she didn't get them hemmed or
anything yeah I think she got capris but
it was perfect yeah
so yeah when didn't yell drop the bomb
at first I was like oh this Danielle's a
[ __ ] like obviously Tracy didn't say
that she's just now throwing Teresa
under the bus because it appears like
Teresa threw her under the bus telling
Melissa to come and say you're out of
the group and so at first I was like I
was like oh well this is just now I
understand might resending el are
fighting currently because danielle made
some [ __ ] up about Teresa totally and
then they put on the receipt like it was
nothing literal and by the way the way
Teresa just said do it like it do it do
it do it
it was so evil evil I love Margaret like
I feel the need to defend her and I
should by the way she does a good job of
doing it herself and everyone on the
show she has good friends like Melissa
and Jackie who will go to bat for her
but like I feel protective of Margaret
she's this.p job she's always been so
nice to us like I just love her and to
know that a she got her hair pulled like
breaks my heart but you know that it was
like a coordinated attack amongst
multiple people like that breaks my
heart even more mm-hmm and I said weeks
ago that Margaret should not be friends
with Teresa and now I stand my ground
and what's annoying is that next week
obviously justice will be served but
then she goes to Italy and Joe and he's
like you remember why
it's a pass and it's it's it's really
annoying timing personally I I agree and
from the vibe that I get now based on
like Instagram and stuff is that
Margaret and Teresa are fine I think
Margaret like finds out about this but
doesn't make it like I I think she again
forgives and it's just so annoying and
frustrating to watch a show where like
one of the main characters is never
gonna be held accountable it's like Lisa
Vanderpump
it's like NeNe Leakes - but like Lisa
man apartment NeNe Leakes anyone is
replaceable and so I did you watch watch
what happens live know who was on
Jennifer and Erica Jane oh I saw some
clips actually this morning and they
said that the reunion is crazy and I'm
sure that it is also when it comes to
that fight at Steven Dan so Margaret
obviously made it physical first by
pouring the water on Danielle and then
Danielle like retaliated by throwing all
of her the contents of her bag in the
camp and it was equal and it was equal
and if it was just that people wouldn't
have been like Danielle needs to go yeah
so it was the hair pole that puts things
over the edge and like that really made
it you know pouring water on someone is
annoying but it's not harmful and
throwing someone's bag in a $500 candle
is annoying but not harmful but Danielle
made it like physical and violent she
had a felony and now we know that it's
Teresa who pulled the trigger
yeah so it changes everything
everything and the fact that all these
weeks oh and Teresa not being invited to
the Mother's Day brunch like oh right
right duh Pigalle butthurt when
literally Martin didn't even realize the
reason I shot her hair pulled was
because of Teresa I'm sorry
Teresa's the [ __ ] worse the worst and
it pains me because I watch this like
scenes where she's going through so much
like hardship and I just like wanna like
be there for her but then it's like
she's so indefensible and she's such a
bad [ __ ] friend yeah she's not that's
not a friend no not at all it's crazy
but now I mean Danielle finally turned
on Teresa oh yeah you know really
quickly um talk about Shahs of Sunset
because I only caught up yesterday yeah
but I just want to say one thing
what if they hadn't had the footage of
Teresa saying do it what I had well do
you have the lead hang out no no I
didn't believe her when she first said
it and then they showed the footage yeah
but I would have just been glad that she
said it because it would have caused a
ripple
yells lying on Teresa's I would say I
wouldn't have really cared whether it
was true or not
but seeing the footage he was so
chilling yeah I wouldn't have believed
it
no I didn't believe it I really want to
talk about chance of sunset because it's
only the second episode and oh my god
like it is literally the kraits the
craziest show I've ever seen in my life
like literally second episode there's a
huge fight drinks being poured on Allie
it was just so nuts and by the way part
of what I love about the show is like
the culture that it brings because it's
partially our culture like it was
Passover Mike Schuh head who was I think
one of one cast member who's Jewish but
they're all like Persian and they're all
Iranian so it's like the same vibe but
like different religions and they all go
to Passover and they like know that they
know the rituals and it's just it's so
refreshing to like see a show where
people are like like no 1 on TV like
he's like religious do you know what I
mean and they're like so many moments on
Shahs of Sunset we're like this last
episode Mike and Mike and Reza were at a
kosher bakery and they sat outside for a
minute like had a macaroon and this
rabbi walked by and Chuck tapped Mike
and was like are you Jewish and he was
like yeah and the rabbi it was like rim
random an on the street and was like can
I put two Pilon on you and Mike was like
yeah sure and then Mike was explaining
how this guy's a rabbi in training and
like it's a mitzvah for rabbis and
training to give random people the
mitzvah of tefillin so it's just like
when the [ __ ] what other show are you
ever gonna see anything like that on
television yeah and then there's just
like so many nuances from like both
cultures cuz half like Reza is
half-jewish half-muslim GG's Muslim
Mike's Jewish MJ's Muslim so it's like
they all are so proud of their culture
and it's like so cool to just like I
don't know if just nobody on TV does
that so you have the combination of like
you get teary eyed like watching them
all do Passover when like their families
fled Iran and then you also get like
Reza throwing a drink at someone because
he said his husband was playing naked
Jenga right now the crux of the argument
is that Reza's out here defending his
husband who his husband is being a [ __ ]
like his husband is the cause of all
this this strife his husband is like
sending really inappropriate text
messages to a lot of their gay and
straight friends like borderline
harassment he's inviting people over his
house like to play naked Jenga and
Reza's like out here on the streets
defending his husband and Reza's very
rational but he's defending his husband
and this husband is indefensible so he's
getting in all these
when he's totally in the wrong because
he's defending his husband who isn't
being a [ __ ] and honestly like I'm just
I'm hating his eyes man his husband's
ruining the season like he's so dumb
he's making recipe in the wrong like
Reza was totally wrong this episode but
he was just defending his husband's like
you have to respect that you know yeah
but his husband is just the worst I've
been catching up on TV I'm gonna start
this season of Shahs I please it's
Jackie you know love you're making it
sound so good night buddy I need your
your brain like you will just have such
and I know you don't watch like try and
watch like a season ago so you can
understand the dynamics and the season
and I used to watch so I I feel like I
all I missed was like I don't even know
all you missed was like the new people
who destiny comes in she's like such and
I saw the AUSA but she's but I heard it
for me so many times and she's gone but
that was just like if you want to be
entertained like that was iconic
television I've also been catching up on
Siesta Key oh yes and I just want to say
I'm only on like the middle of episode
three but Chloe got physical first with
Juliet 1,000% but no one can remember
they were so [ __ ] up
they were so [ __ ] up Jackie of course
um but it's like right there plain as
day but then they can't remember it I
just saw that was really frustrating
like can someone just explaining that
Chloe got physical first we talked about
how dumb the boutique is the boot I'm
not there yet
yes you are the boutique Juliet's
working at the boutique and they haven't
showed footage yet oh my god it's like
so dumb she's like asking for time off
to go to Greece with Robby and Lady
cheek owners like this is my business
like she's just like I'm like [ __ ]
Julianne's bring you guys to your dumb
boutique let her go to Greece that is so
funny and then you know what else I
watched yesterday in the soup the new
suit wasn't it you know what I really
liked it really yeah Jade cata Preta is
so great and so cute and she was she was
great but then I liked her I saw her on
the pop and I was like who is this girl
usually I hate everyone and she was I
liked her a lot
I like she had just such great energy
but my favorite part about the soup
which was what made it so great it's
like they seriously watch everything
that's on TV and they just cut these
clips that out of context are so what
did they go oh my god they cut they cut
something from Shahs that was really
funny but then they cut so they come
from jealous uh when when sewed ends
when Reza is like - Adam do you play
naked Jenga and then it's to be
continued it's just ridiculous and
and when it's taken out of context it's
even funnier they cut something from
90-day fiance or married at first sight
one of those shows where the woman was
like I got married a few years ago and
we had like two children together and
then one day she was like I remember it
was just like so sad my husband he
tripped and he fell into his co-workers
vagina and he's been stuck there ever
since and it was just like just getting
clips of shows that I don't watch or
like even they clipped one babe from spy
games and it was the Bravo show yeah and
it's like we're gonna hold you off the
side of the building and ask you
questions which was just weird enough
and then the director I guess says you
know a lot of times you're asked you
know insane like really hard questions
in in dangerous situations and you know
I can't put you in front of a member of
Isis but I can put you off the side of a
building what that show looks so strange
and so I just want to say I'm really
glad that the super is back interesting
maybe I'm gonna watch it yeah it was
funny
oh well that's your TV recap there's
anything on tonight now we're done with
TV for the week yeah so I'm gonna I
started a new book last night and I'm
gonna catch up on Siesta Key Shahs I'm
just gonna spend the weekend watching TV
like there's nothing else I want to do
those are the best types of week out is
that I feel like I haven't done a binge
watch in a long time because I've been
binge reading yeah but I think it's time
to go I've been binge-watching enough
for the both of us yeah if you haven't
got your merch at the st. Paddy's stay
toasty kiss me I'm toasty merch head
over to shop morning toast calm right
now the orders are only being taken in
to Hill twelve Eastern because we
decided to do pre-orders so head over to
shop morning toast calm thank you so
much for listening to the morning toast
millennium morning show where we go live
money the Friday 10:30 a.m. Eastern Time
on YouTube so if you're watching us on
YouTube please feel free to subscribe
give this video a thumbs up we're also
available as a podcast anywhere products
can be found so it's about if I didn't
set your public video I have radio cash
box all the places you can find podcasts
wherever you choose to listen to
podcasts find us the morning hi how are
you maybe subscribe maybe leave a
five-star review about how beautiful
stunning and smart we are
I don't know how check it out vo is and
how good of a boy he well we love you
guys so much have a great day